on va regarder maintenant un peu plus en
détail le résultat de benoît hamon dans
les yvelines résultats du parti
socialiste le coût est encore plus rude
le ps poursuit cette chute infernale
entamé en 2014 avec les élections
municipales sur l'ensemble du
département des yvelines benoît hamon la
termine comme sur le plan national 5e
6,93 % des suffrages exprimés en score 4
fois plus faible que celui de françois
hollande en 2012 benoît hamon termine
deuxième pire encore donc dans son fief
électoral attrape avec 24% des voix
derrière jean-luc mélenchon 30 2% alors
à qui la faute les avis sont partagés au
sein du ps dans le département avec une
ligne qui préfèrent défendre benoît
hamon victimes notamment de la mauvaise
image du ps ces cinq dernières années et
coûter malgré un programme qui était
intéressant malgré la personnalité de
nos amours sûr que quand on demande aux
gens ils vous disent pas finalement son
pouvoir était cohérent et intéressant
lui-même c'est quelqu'un de bien mais
c'étaient d'autres enjeux sur cette
élection est en bois qui est à la fois
un rejet de la politique qui a été menée
et en même temps très clairement un vote
utile qui a fonctionné à plein et qui a
siphonné l'électorat traditionnel on va
dire électorale sur lesquelles on
pouvait se s'appuyer amicalement il a
peut-être été mal compris ou en tout cas
c'est pas ces enjeux qui ont été les
plus mis en avant dans cette dans cette
élection
la faute aux affaires notamment
puisqu'on a un monde politique qui n'est
pas qui n'est pas sain de manière
générale et c'est particulièrement
sortie pendant pendant cette élection et
c'est dommageable pour le débat
démocratique qui aurait dû avoir lieu
a contrario certains estiment que benoît
hamon n'a pas su incarner le
rassemblement au sein de son parti en
cherchant à rallier vers lui tout
d'abord les militants de la france
insoumise c'est le cas notamment de la
sénatrice socialiste catherine tasca
benoît hamon maintenant s'étonne de ne
pas avoir eu le support qui lui était dû
en tant que candidat du parti socialiste
mais ça n'est pas étonnant puisque il a
embarqué le lac sa campagne sur une
ligne qui n'a jamais était la ligne
majoritaire des socialistes donc
effectivement il s'est retrouvé à ses
seuls dans dans cette campagne
mon par ailleurs il n'a donné aucun
signe de rassemblement ni au sein du ps
ni en direction des partenaires
possibles et la prochaine étape qui sera
compliqué ce sont ces élections
législatives de juin le ps ne compte que
deux députés dans les yvelines dont la
11e circonscription détenue par
justement un certain benoît hamon
stéphane samson c'est la disparition des
socialistes du parti socialiste c'est la
disparition du parti socialiste version
françois mitterrand parti d'epinay 1971
puisque le le score qu'il obtient est à
peu près à peu de choses près équivalent
à celui de gaston defferre avait obtenu
169 au président sa relation du ps et
une redistribution des cartes à il va
faire l'argent 500 milles oui mais le ps
peut se reconstruire mais il va falloir
être clair sur pour savoir sur quel base
et peut-être abandonné le système des
courants qui avait fait jusqu'à l'heure
son succès vous avez essayé de mettre
tout le monde d'accord en mettant sous
le tapis les sujets qui fâchent est là
c'est clair qu'aujourd'hui il va falloir
faire effectivement le tri sur les
différentes mouvances le